[Music]
hi mystery recap here today i am going
to explain an american science fiction
comedy family film called honey i blew
up the kid
spoilers ahead watch out and take care
[Music]
the movie centers around a family of
five the celinski family the father
wayne is an inventor who invents
household things that help his family
work efficiently in the opening scene we
see an automated mailbox that receives
the daily newspaper the family dog runs
to the box every morning and picks a
bone attached to it because of it the
newspaper drops below and he brings it
back to his master even the neighbors
are amazed by the innovation other than
that wayne has made a helmet for himself
that helps him shave a sound system that
helps his wife call the children when
breakfast is ready and many other
inventions similar to those one day
wayne's wife diane is flying to another
state to see off her eldest daughter amy
to college she will be gone for a few
days and wants her husband to take good
care of their middle child nick and the
youngest adam after she leaves wayne
rushes to his job and is late as usual
he works at sterling labs of innovation
his project partner dr charles is not
fond of wayne because he is better than
him hence the doctor tries to exclude
wayne from the experiments as much as
possible a few years ago wayne developed
a prototype that could shrink people and
objects into a miniscule size currently
the lab is trying to develop a device
that does the opposite dr charles tests
the prototype by using it on a crystal
at first the crystal grows as expected
but right when the team thinks the
experiment worked it wiggles and
explodes all over dr charles's face he
is disappointed to say the least he is
being pressured by the company's
president and the u.s government to
complete the prototype soon wayne has
innovative ideas that could help them
but dr charles refuses to listen to him
at home chaos ensues because of diane's
absence the guys burn food in the
microwave every time they use it diane
calls them and asks them to heat the
chicken that she made before leaving
with burnt chicken in front of him wayne
lies to her that it tastes delicious at
last they have to settle with peanut
butter and toast for dinner after that
wayne tucks adam into sleep and sings
him a lullaby along with his favorite
toy big bunny while he is at it he
suddenly gets the idea of why the
crystal exploded that day at work he
calls dr charles and explains his theory
but the man dismisses him he thinks that
wayne is an idiot incapable of such
advanced inventions the following day is
the weekend but wayne comes to work
along with his kids he has planned to
make the required changes to the
prototype without informing dr charles
the lab guard sees him go inside without
registering his name and calls dr
charles to inform him in the meantime
wayne fixes the problem and decides to
use the prototype on adam's toy big
bunny as the countdown starts adam goes
to the platform to get his toy and is
hit with the light wave coming from the
prototype when everything goes silent
wayne sees that his idea didn't work and
returns home with the kids unaware that
his son was blasted with a ray of
radiation as they leave the guard
comments that adam has grown bigger but
no one thinks much of it the guard
noticed what adam's own father did not
that guard is kinda sus
on their way back home nick asks wayne
why he needs dr charles's permission to
work on his own invention it turns out
the idea and initial plan was wayne's
but since his partner dr charles doesn't
like him he has taken over the project
at home wayne quickly calls nick's crush
mandy to come and babysit adam he and
nick want to go out to the movies for
father-son time when adam is alone in
the kitchen he is exposed to electrical
waves from the microwave oven this
causes him to grow over seven feet tall
because of the radiation he received
earlier when his father and brother see
him they are beyond surprised they soon
realized that adam was exposed to
radiation from the prototype they
immediately decide to return to the lab
and reverse the process to avoid walking
in with a seven foot tall baby they
disguise adam to the best of his
abilities however they are stopped by dr
charles who kicks wayne out of the
project it turns out that because of the
experiment wayne had conducted earlier a
power surge occurred which deleted all
the information about the experiment
disheartened wayne returns home hoping
to get adam back to normal before diane
gets back but his plan fails when he
sees her waiting for them with big bunny
who has grown large like adam at first
they try to run away so she won't see
the grown baby but knowing that they
cannot hide for long wayne comes clean
to his wife when she gets a look at adam
she passes out in shock as wayne wakes
her up nick tries to get adam to sit
down the baby plays around and destroys
half the things in the house when he is
locked in the room he opens the entire
door and brings it outside by now the
neighbors have gathered outside
zelinski's residence because of all the
noise after running around for almost an
hour trying to catch him they finally
calm him down and put him into a bigger
playpen wayne gets a chance to think of
the reason the kid grew when he was
brought home and not when he was hit
with radiation although he doesn't get
the answers he remembers that his old
prototype could shrink people down the
device is currently stored in the
sterling warehouse if they can bring it
back there is a chance that adam will be
brought back to his normal size
wayne then makes adam take a nap he and
diane go to retrieve the first prototype
while nick takes the responsibility to
keep an eye on adam after the parents
leave mandy arrives at the house to
babysit nick tries sending her away but
she sees adam and freaks out with no way
out he ties her to a chair and gags her
so she wouldn't run away or tell anyone
in the meantime the parents arrive at
the warehouse that has hundreds of
crates they look around and finally find
the prototype they are looking for back
in the house nick tries explaining
everything to mandy adam is watching the
tv in the other room the radiation from
the tv makes him get even taller he runs
away from the house nick and mandy run
outside to look for him while adam
wreaks havoc in the neighborhood he is
sitting in the middle of the street with
his bunny while a crowd watches
dr charles also sees this and realizes
why wayne was in the lab on the weekend
wayne and diane are on their way back
home diane is driving while wayne is
fixing his old prototype in the back of
the car they are followed by two
policemen for speeding wayne uses the
prototype on them and shrinks the two
wayne probably just murdered those
police this has escalated quickly before
escaping he turns them back to their
normal size leaving them amazed oh never
mind dr charles takes the responsibility
to handle the situation with adam he
wants to use the chaos that adam has
caused to drive the president against
wayne he has already sent adam to the
lab to get tested when his parents
return on their way to the lab adam gets
struck with a bigger wave of radiation
because of the electric cables this
grows his size even more and he escapes
from the van the president of sterling
lab clifford finally arrives at the
silinsky residence dr charles tells him
that everything was wayne's fault but
the president is impressed by wayne for
doing what the other scientists couldn't
he fires dr charles for not being a team
worker and helps wayne a policeman
informs them of adam's escape and they
run to save him meanwhile dr charles
calls a board member of sterling's lab
named terence who agrees to help them
get his position back on their way to
get adam clifford and wayne come to
realize that he is growing in size
because of electromagnetic flux since
adam is making his way to las vegas he
is going to grow even bigger because of
the neon signs dr charles meets terrence
who brings him back to the team using
his authority as a board member dr
charles wants to use the military to
stop the havoc everyone finally makes it
to the highway that adam is on they are
shocked to see that he has grown into a
giant for the shrinking prototype to
work the kid has to hold still for 12
seconds which the parents think is
impossible he comes closer to them
revealing that nick and mandy are inside
his pockets just then wayne comes up
with an idea he calls the police to
bring big bunny to adam a helicopter
brings the toy to the kid as wayne sings
a lullaby the plan works and adam is
about to sleep when wayne mentions he
has to take a nap adam who has always
hated the word nap refuses to sleep
after that then he walks to las vegas
threatening to destroy everything on his
way somewhere else dr charles gets ready
with a tranquilizer gun and a helicopter
to sedate the kid even though it means
severe health risks adam finally reaches
the city and starts running around the
streets a crowd of people gathers to see
him some of them running away to save
their lives the street lights and signs
amuse him making him even more frantic
when he bends down mandy and nick
managed to climb down to a yellow car
but adam picks it up and swings it in
the air to play with it he places them
on a billboard where they hang
dangerously as the crowd watches holding
its breath he finally puts the car
inside his pockets not harming his
brother and mandy in any way following
that wayne gets another one of his great
ideas he knows that adam likes ice cream
more than anything in his life hence he
plans to lure him into a secluded
highway using an ice cream truck the
plan works and adam chases behind the
truck however he closes on it quickly
and the driver has to stop to save his
life then dr charles arrives at the
scene on a helicopter with a
tranquilizer gun he misses the first
shot while the second one lands on a
guitar the kid is holding it hurts adam
and he begins to cry at last diane
volunteers to be shot by the prototype
so she can be bigger than adam and hold
him down after being hit by the
radiation she grows even taller than the
skyscrapers adam sees her and stops
crying as the two hug wayne shoots them
with his first prototype and turns them
back into their normal sizes after
everything calms down diane punches dr
charles in the face for trying to hurt
her son all of a sudden they remember
that nick and mandy were in adam's
pocket meaning that they might have
turned minuscule because of the
prototype they used their dog to look
for them it turns out that they are
stuck in a tiny car mandy compliments
nick saying that he is different from
most guys she meets she leans on his
shoulders making him blush wayne soon
finds him and the story ends happily
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching